when you think about the word
Scientology what does it mean I'd rather
be dead than to be the seriously you say
that oh absolutely I contemplated just
driving into a wall and just killing her
you're being serious
absolutely suicide death would be a
better existence than living there when
you see beating people wouldn't wouldn't
punching with your fists into the face
we'd be in meanings and he would punch
people in the mood like while they're
sitting can you say and this is so hard
to believe though how can an
organization do that period under the
guise of religion you have thousands and
thousands of these little aliens
attached to you I have aliens attached
to everybody does especially you I do
get some brilliance or the people who
represented the government that approved
it to be a religion are idiots
you
[Music]